hey guys and welcome to in two minutes
the show that is usually about video
games but as you may have noticed we are
suffering from something of a sunny
summary drought right about now
thankfully while the video game industry
takes a nap those crazy kids in
Hollywood are raising the roof with all
kinds of exciting movie things I hear
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is kind of
a big thing and so far this year we've
already had age of Ultron but luckily
2015 is big enough for two superhero
movies especially when one of those
heroes is this big so what is this an in
two minutes for ants well kind of given
his size you may not have paid much
attention to ant-man so you may be
surprised to hear that he's been helping
save the world in comics since the early
60s so now that he's said to and pause
for effect again become huge thanks to
his own blockbuster movie it's
definitely worth taking the time to clue
yourself up on the character so let's
ask the question then who is the ant-man
that was a dumb question in the movie at
Scott Lang but Scott lying isn't the
only person to take on the ant mantle
the first was Hank played by Michael
Douglas Pym who shows up in the movie as
Scott's mentor Pym is a brilliant
biophysicist who discovers a weird group
of subatomic particles that he named Pym
particles from these he synthesized two
serums one shrinks objects and people
and the other m begins them back after
one shrinking spell leaves him trapped
in an anthill which is a problem I think
we can all relate to him finds himself
fascinated with the creatures he
construct a cybernetic helmet that
allows him to communicate with the bitee
buggers and fashions a suit infused with
the Pym particles to allow him to shrink
down and thus an ant-man was born a
skilled hand-to-hand combatant and a
certified genius his prolonged exposure
to Pym particles eventually allowed him
to shrink to the size of her well I
think you know the answer to this one at
will the bonus is the smaller he gets
the stronger he gets don't think about
that part too much it's kind of like how
Peter Parker gained the proportional
strength of a spider when he became
Spidey and
it wouldn't be Marvel without a
character having a few alternate aliases
Hank also becomes wasp after his wife
Janet Van Dyne dies then there's Goliath
and giant man where he uses the Pym
particles to vastly increase his size
now despite ant-man being Hanks first
appearance in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe he's been an incredibly
important character in the comics not
only were he and Janet founding members
of the Avengers Hank also created Ultron
you know that sentient robot Tony Stark
made in the movie universe the one that
was all no strings on me and then just
started destroying everything after Pym
two more people have been ant-man as
SHIELD agent Eric O'Grady who nabbed Ant
Man armor from shield stores for his own
personal gain including trying to use it
to get the ladies and then this Scott
crapbag from friends Lang an electronic
expert and petty criminal he's trying to
get his life together to save his sick
daughter and the best way to get your
life together is of course to put on a
fancy suit and become an Ernst
now I don't want to go with steep of
risk of movie spoilers but at least now
you have a basic grasp on the ant-man
character and how he fits into the wider
Marvel Universe that's all from me this
week but you can find me on Twitter at
Lucy James games although i'll be
spending the majority of my days talking
to an ant farm and seeing where that
gets me i'll see you next time
I down again without as much puzzle face
exciting movies don't really write that
that doesn't sound like me I don't
usually that excited about things who is
Scott wine kids who is on man